you're very emotional very careful you
clearly feel the South African
authorities have let you down yes so
many L said yes of them just go so will
you be will you be fighting further
together ok Annie's father there's
absolutely Shelton better but he did not
feel that justice had been done clearly
a very very emotional extremely angry
family difficult to talk to them at this
moment because they are so emotional but
her sister was absolutely even despite
her emotional absolutely clear she did
not feel the justice had been done she
filled with the justice system has left
them down and I'm sure that's an
indication they've got their hands of
their eyes if this family is very
distraught all of them pretty much all
of them cry and Annie's father
absolutely spitting with fury wonder
whether we can get a bit close for going
and take much more traction and see
whether we can then get against of them
through the window yeah they've got
their hands up to their faces they are
very very upset